[Music]
on this Saturday night calling for
change in Iran around the world and
right here in Canada
protesters not backing down
from respected filmmaker to living in a
tent new details about the man accused
of killing an RCMP officer
taking a bite out of inflation why some
experts say switching grocery stores
could be a smart choice
and siren Call we're the next generation
of stewards of the land how a
firefighting course could be the
beginning of meaningful careers for
indigenous youth
global national with para Nasser
good evening and thank you for joining
us tens of thousands of people gathered
in cities around the world today to show
solidarity with protesters in Iran
for more than a month Iranians have been
taking to the streets in anti-government
demonstrations sparked by the death of
Masa amini the 22 year old died after
being arrested by the so-called morality
police for wearing her hijab too loosely
one of the largest demonstrations today
was in Berlin
there are tens of thousands of people
packed into the city some traveling to
Germany from other countries including
Canada to show support
Mike drolet has more on the growing
worldwide momentum and the response from
Iran
protests condemning the regime in Iran
are nothing new but all this feels
different Toronto's large Iranian
diaspora took to the streets to demand
change within Iran
delivering the same message on political
and human rights as groups did in
Halifax and other cities across Canada
[Applause]
all right European cities saw similar
protests by far the largest was in
Berlin with 80 000 people speaking for
one I am in his voice Masa amini was 22
years old when she was detained in
mid-september by Iran's morality police
for not wearing a hijab correctly her
suspicious death while in custody set
off a series of protests and riots
throughout the country
which five weeks later continued to
gather Steam on Friday night protesters
chanted for a regime change in the
normally quiet city of zaidon Hardline
clerics within Iran have urged Security
Forces to respond with force and they've
obliged over 200 protesters have
reportedly been killed and thousands
more arrested facing pressure at the
United Nations Iran was unequivocal stay
out of our business we advise those
western states that they are not
required to act as guardians or
caretakers of Iranian women or speak on
their behalf yet enough women in Iran
are doing just that by publicly and
defiantly cutting off their hair
and this week the regime faced yet
another crisis when professional climber
El nazrakabi competed in South Korea
without her hijab
all eyes were on her when she returned
to Tehran
where she said she had made a mistake
and forgot to wear it a statement human
rights groups believe was coerced they
now worry she's under house arrest
unable to speak her mind
is why these protests show no signs of
letting up microlyte Global News Toronto
[Music]
China's president has strengthened his
power this weekend cementing his status
in the country's ruling Communist Party
the once in five years Congress amended
the party's Constitution to solidify XI
jinping's role but the usually highly
choreographed meeting included an
unexpected element the president's
immediate predecessor hujin Tao was
escorted out of the closing ceremony the
79 year old had been seated next to XI
and looked distressed as he was led off
stage by two men Chinese State media is
reporting that two was removed because
he felt unwell
and we're learning more details about a
man accused of killing RCMP Constable
shailen Yang in British Columbia this
week zhongwon ham had been living in a
tent in a park but before that he lived
and worked in Toronto as an
award-winning filmmaker Romina Daya has
the details on what a friend close to
him describes as a downward spiral
[Music]
how did 37 year old zhongwon ham go from
talented actor and Emmy award-winning
filmmaker to living in a tent in Burnaby
now charged with the first degree murder
of our CMP Constable shailin yang
an impressive resume of film and
television work spanning nearly a decade
starring here in a Korean short film for
which he won the audience Choice Award
in 2013.
one of Ham's close friends tells us he's
devastated he says ham was falsely
accused of sex assault in Toronto years
ago and the strain of that investigation
sent ham to a dark place
a social media post on Ham's page saying
what's next entrapment Global News has
confirmed with police sources in BC and
Ontario ham was charged with sexual
assault in Toronto in 2014 but it took
three years before the charge was
withdrawn for him catastrophic damage
had been done a mental health downward
spiral ensuit ham lost contact with
friends and disappeared from social
media four years ago somehow he makes
his way west
according to court documents ham was
living in Vancouver near King's weight
and Knight Street ham was sharing
Penthouse number three with a roommate
then in January of last year a 9-1-1
call police confirmed the roommate was
worried for his safety because of an
alleged death threat a neighbor tells us
ham was paranoid he agrees to leave the
building a string of charges follows
assault resisting of police officer and
assault again in March of this year in
and out of jail ham now living in a tent
washing his socks in the fountain he had
been removed from the park but was back
another warning to leave coming down
Tuesday when Constable Yang is killed
a shocking Fall From Grace for respected
Rising Star Ham's next appearance will
be in a Vancouver courtroom November 2nd
to deal with the murder charge Romina
Daya Global News
turning now to the war in Ukraine
Russian officials are warning residents
in the southern city of Curson to leave
immediately ahead of an expected
Ukrainian Advance over the last few days
thousands of people have been leaving
the city by crossing a major river they
are being moved deeper into russian-held
territory Ukrainian forces are hoping to
retake the city which has been under
Russian control since the early days of
the war the cost of food is a big
concern right now food inflation has
surged to a 41-year high climbing faster
than overall inflation which is cooled
slightly in the past few weeks that's
forced households to cut back on dining
out and on groceries many Wonder of
switching grocery stores can help them
save even more and gaviola has more on
what the experts are suggesting
brand loyalty is out saving on your
grocery bill is in we're seeing an
uptake uh in consumers wanting to shop
at lower end grocery stores though
places where they may not have all the
bells and whistles because they're
getting a better price food inflation
means your dollars don't go as far as
they used to the days of shopping where
you've always shopped because it's close
to home or work are over for many I see
between stores which ones are cheaper
and I go there cereal pasta and baked
goods prices are up about 18 percent in
the past year fresh fruit 13 more
expensive fresh vegetables 12 for a lot
of us it now means buying Frozen the
nutrients the the goodness in them is
locked in they may not look as good or
as taste as good as the fresh but
they're typically cheaper prices of
citrus fruits berries nuts lettuce all
items we import from the US and Mexico
are going to continue climbing as winter
weather adds time and cost to
transporting them the weaker Canadian
dollar is a fact II so were Rising
fertilizer pesticide and labor costs
Loblaw announced a price freeze on 1500
no-name brand items and Metro says it's
not accepting price increases from
suppliers for the next three months
critics call these PR moves that make
headlines but don't reduce your bills
they're freezing prices at these
elevated levels it's not like they're
bringing prices down and actually making
a difference switching from a
full-service grocer with lots of
prepared food options to something more
basic is one way to save but not if it
involves paying more for gas if you're
having to travel across town or or drive
long distances to get a one cheaper
product you know you're spending a lot
on fuel that's a bit of a waste of money
instead pay attention to the cost per
unit which will make you savvier at
spotting Real Deals and not getting
duped by shrinkflation with the Bank of
Canada likely to roll out another big
rate hike in an effort to tame inflation
this labor Economist says low-income
households are on the brink if we don't
do more more people are going to to go
hungry and have to make a choice
actually between Heating and heating in
the coming months because of what's
happening to gas prices and what's
happening to the prices of basic
foodstuffs the cost of living pushing
more Canadians to make difficult
decisions and gaviola Global News
Toronto
coming up warning signs how Quebec is
working to prevent future deaths after a
string of murders of children
the grizzly murderers of two children by
their own father this week in Quebec has
left people asking how these deaths can
be prevented just last month another
father was charged with murdering his
children and his wife experts say events
like these happen all too frequently in
that Province and as Amanda jalowicki
reports they say more resources are
needed and warning signs need Heating
outside this home on a quiet
neighborhood street north of Montreal a
makeshift Memorial grows a mark of
inexplicable sadness for the horror that
happened inside
police arrested and charged camel jet
Aurora with murdering his 13-year-old
daughter and 11 year old son innocent
children being killed this is unheard of
I mean what are we becoming here Quebec
has a grisly history of high-profile
filicides
the case of cardiologist gee turcotte
captivated the country after separating
from his wife he slaughtered his two
children
years ago a province-wide Manhunt from
Martin Carpentier ended when police
found the bludgeoned bodies of his two
daughters
The Province was left bereft after
Jonathan pamara's butchered his two
children in 2019. you've heard the term
zero to 100 they don't go from zero to a
hundred they're already at 75.
Carrollton James runs
Ross Clinic focused
points to many tickles in helping them
the major challenges engaging them to
begin with but often tend to minimize
often have very little self-awareness or
insight into their own behavior
around 30 to 40 kids in Canada are
killed each year by their parents
experts say partner violence often leads
to violence against children
three quarters of child homicides are
predictable and preventable when parents
kill children it's never under the blue
there's usually
warning signs those warnings include a
history of depression or mental health
issues addiction issues around
separation and repeated domestic
violence while the violence is
continuing
there should be less contact between the
spouses and less manipulation of the
children we have to learn lessons from
these tragedies you know we can't bring
back children who are gone but we should
be working damn hard to make sure we
prevent future deaths deaths that leave
everybody asking
Global News Montreal
I had the mighty Mississippi drying up
how drought for one of the largest
rivers in the U.S could have an effect
on the economy
in the U.S the worst drought in at least
a decade has caused water levels in the
Mississippi River to drop to Historic
lows slowing down America's supply chain
the mighty River supports a 12.6 billion
dollar shipping industry and tens of
thousands of jobs but is going dry in
several sections and as Jennifer Johnson
reports shipping delays will mean even
higher consumer costs
the mighty Mississippi America's second
largest river is not Mighty anymore
drought conditions are bringing this
vital Transportation Waterway to a halt
over 120 vessels and more than 1800
barges are backed up because of at least
four closures well I'm not going to
sugarcoat it it is it's bad we know how
important this economic impact is to the
United States massive barges carrying
everything from crops to steel or
crawling along or stopped delays will
further drive up consumer costs at a
time when inflation is at its highest
level in 40 years food prices are going
up Energy prices might be impacted those
are the implications for people I think
on a day-to-day basis sixty percent of
All Grain exported from the U.S goes
down this River to New Orleans and is
shipped worldwide farmers who can't move
their crops are seeing their profits dry
up causing us to even lose money you
know on the crop that we grew Roger
Smith estimates the shipping delays and
cancellations will cost him forty
thousand dollars this year parts of the
river like in Memphis Tennessee are at
the lowest level in 70 years maybe your
record lows the lower than normal uh I
would say that this year
fits that description the U.S Army Corps
of Engineers has been brought in to
regulate traffic and deepen channels to
keep barges from running aground
sometimes a walking path
it can get that severe but while
Industries wait and hope no major barge
gets stuck shutting the whole Waterway
down archaeologists are making
discoveries they never imagined
century-old shipwrecks are coming to
life as the waters recede 15 years I've
been an office-bound bureaucrat and so
this is one of the cooler things I've
seen in those 15 years
unfortunately rain hasn't been seen too
often either and industries that rely on
this River are hoping Mother Nature will
come to the rescue but significant
amounts of precipitation are not in the
forecast as this river which runs
through 10 states continues to shrink
Jennifer Johnson Global News Washington
[Music]
next igniting careers how obesity-based
training program is helping to spark
into firefighting
[Music]
recent rain and the cooler temperatures
we've seen across Canada are bringing
some relief to what's being a Fierce and
long-running Fire season in BC where
more than 200 fires are still burning a
training program is helping to ignite
interest for young Canadians to become
firefighters it's a profession that will
likely be relied on more heavily going
forward the course is open to anyone but
as Kylie Stanton reports its hope that
First Nations youth in particular hear
the siren Call
this turns on they start with the basics
and work their way up participants here
are learning the ins and outs of
fighting fires you want to come down
your body but the real goal is to light
a spark so far we've learned a lot about
the equipment this is going to be a
relay rate yeah 60 seconds each
essentially
how to put it on and take it off we just
did some communication drills with the
walkie-talkies stretch them out coffee
the First Nations Emergency Services
society's fire prevention youth boot
camp has everyone fired up
a three-day course possibly the start of
some long and meaningful careers we feel
that the First Nations youth can be the
the future the stewards of the land
moving forward and able to protect their
homes and communities
with the number of volunteer
firefighters on the decline and those
who came before them getting older the
knowledge is ready to be passed on they
know the land they know the culture and
the Demand only continues to grow not
only to structure firefighting but BC
wildfire and all the different aspects
of those
for hundreds if not thousands of years
First Nations have been making the land
safer for everyone through cultural
burning practices and the purpose of
this is actually to reduce some fuel
loading if done properly it helps to
thin out the forests get rid of the
fuels while releasing nutrients bring
the hose line around the hope is by
opening the door here it will ignite
something in First Nations youth
excellent yeah
ultimately bringing them back to their
land more than next generation of
stewards of the land so it's important
to remember that
as we move forward
and that's global national for this
Saturday night I'm Farah Nasser on
behalf of our whole team here at global
national I want to thank you so much for
spending part of your evening with us
tonight's your Canada is near Mata BC we
love seeing your Canada so please keep
emailing us those photos to viewers at
globalnational.com
until next time take care of yourselves
and each other good night
[Music]
thank you